hey youtubers it's Charlie this week's
supernatural took a relaxing spa break
from the war for heaven and hell and
what I like to think of as a cross
between an x-files episode and a
scooby-doo mystery special shout out to
lunch lady Dean second only to dog Dean
quick heads-up though because of the
Olympic supernatural won't be back till
the 25th so if you're looking to rewatch
some episodes I would recommend
firstborn or anything with Abaddon to
Crowley in it since this was a
particularly ridiculous episode I'm
gonna do my top 5 funny moments and then
I'll do my review number 5 sheriff Donna
Dean and doughnuts
Dean eating like a pig is always
hilarious but we have to give credit to
sheriff Donna for being his wingman on
this joke
she was just casually stuffing her face
with white powder on our lips when the
camera cuts the Dean licking his fingers
and looking like he just stuck his whole
face in that box of donuts the best part
of that was that Donna and Dean didn't
say anything about it and Sam just went
oh just sighed number 4 we have all
kinds of certifications they really did
give away lunch lady Dean in the teaser
last week so this wasn't a surprise but
just the preposition of Dean in a
hairnet is epic he gets all the best
fake jobs on the show not to be outdone
though the idea of Sam as Richard
Simmons was pretty good seriously though
can we talk about how Dean is always the
one to jump in headfirst to some crazy
situation and Sam always follows along
even though he's way bigger right now
and hates the [ __ ] out of him
number three everybody do downward dog
for five minutes I've actually done yoga
in five minutes and one post is a lot
but it's not that bad
I did love the look on everyone's faces
though and just the idea that Sam only
knew yoga because he also dated someone
bendy number two fat vampires saying it
that way makes it sound like a really
bad Twilight spin-off but as gross as it
was it was hilarious watching Sam and
Dean react to everything
I couldn't stop mentally associating the
pudding with the jars of fat that they
kept in the fridge if you are able to
get through a cupping session after this
you are a champ
and my number one moment something is
wrong with this pudding
Dean getting roofied is just a little
bit dark because of what roofies are
normally associated with but watching
him lust after the pudding was the
funniest part of the episode you have a
lunch lady Dean getting dumped on by his
supervisor who tells him he can't touch
the pudding so naturally Dean
immediately runs off with some how great
was it that he ran into the closet to
eat it
I just want a clip reel of Sam catching
Dean eating in weird places it's like
catching a dog eating off the table and
then smacking out on the nose
I can just see the crestfallen look on
Dean's face I'm sorry I was hungry so
let me know what your favorite moment
was were you team yoga or team lunch
lady I do have to say though I was
definitely team lunch lady I even sang
the Adam Sandler song in my head just a
little bit overall I have to give the
episode of b-minus just because it was a
retread of old material in a new setting
plus sometimes Sam and Dean's attitudes
on monsters and killing is a little
inconsistent in fairness to Dean though
he still has that Mark of Cain so that
might have been what was making him go
all aggro I did have fun with the fat
vampire twist and the whole concept of
the weight loss spa the health nut slash
eating disorder satire was a nice moral
through-line to moderation is key in all
things both monster and Winchester if
only Dean could just learn to chill on
all the instant gratification he might
be okay
I think a big journey for Dean this
season in addition to killing Abaddon is
learning to be a real human being he's
kind of been living this parody of a
life up to this point which is probably
why he didn't know how to live without
Sam and why he can't ever settle down
this deep into the season I feel like
they really need to be focusing on those
main plot lines though like Crowley
Avedon Castiel and Metatron I am 99%
sure that they are going to get a season
10 so the real question to ask is is
Dean going to learn from this is he
going to grow as a person or is he going
to be experiencing the same problems
next season let me know what you think
though is Dean going to be the same old
Dean in season 10 so in related news if
you didn't see I just posted a big
preview for the new flash TV series you
can click here to get it and you can
click here to get my last supernatural
video thanks so much for watching I'll
see you guys tonight
high fives
you